بعض الصور الجديدة من مستشفى سيناء جريس
في ديترويت تصور مدى
خطورة انتشار الوباء
في مدينة ديترويت التي تملأ
وحدات التجميد ، حتى أن بعضها يتم تخزينه في
غرف احتياطية مخصصة في الأصل لدراسات النوم.
في الوقت الحالي ،
لقد زرت هذا المستشفى مؤخرًا ، هذه
الصور صادمة عندما تراها ،
نعم هذه قصة صعبة.
a
CO vid 19 وما بدأناه هو
عندما بدأنا التحدث إلى هؤلاء
المستجيبين الأبطال الأوائل في جميع أنحاء المدينة
، بدأوا في مشاركة القصص معنا
وهذه إحدى المجموعات التي بدأت
تتحدث عما كان يجري داخل
هذا المستشفى ولكنه  اظهر لكم
بعض الصور هنا تظهر لكم بعض
الصور هنا بعض منها مزعجة لكن
الصورة الاولى التي اريد ان اظهر
لكم بالداخل كانت تعتبر نومه.
قيل لنا إنهم اضطروا إلى تخزين
بعض الجثث هنا
لمدة 12 ساعة على الأقل ربما
بسبب نفاد المساحة في الغرف الأخرى ،
ثم لدينا طلقة أخرى داخل
الثلاجة لكنهم أحضروا المكان الذي
يمكنك  رؤية الجثث فوق بعضها
البعض وبينما كنا نتحدث إلى الموظفين
تعرضوا للإهانة ولكن ما كان
عليهم فعله في الواقع تحدثنا إلى العديد من
العاملين في غرفة الطوارئ الذين أخبرونا بشكل أساسي ليس فقط
أنهم قلقون بشأن
نقص الموظفين وحقيقة وجود الكثير
المرضى الذين يأتون كانوا قلقين
بشأن المرضى الذين كانوا هناك
والذين كانوا يحاولون العناية بهم ولكنهم
لم يرغبوا أبدًا في أن يفقد أي شخص أحد أفراد أسرته
وأن يظل عالقًا في مكان مثل هذا وفي
الواقع ذهب الكثير من الناس إلى أبعد من
ذلك  يقول المصدران أخبرونا على
الأقل أنهما يريدان التأكد من أن
لديهم مساحة سرير كافية للأشخاص الذين
كانوا داخل غرفة الطوارئ ، الجزء الأخير
الذي سأخبرك به أن هذين الشخصين قد ماتا
في الردهة داخل ذلك المستشفى الذي
يوجد به المستشفى  قالوا إنهم دفعوا المزيد من
الموظفين إلى المنطقة لمساعدة
المرضى نوعًا ما ، لذا فإن Jake هذه هي القصة المستمرة
التي ستستمر في متابعتك